Americans almost have this weird
fixation on Scandinavia you know I I
mean in on this topic we want to use
Sweden as the scapegoat uh but then in a
bunch of other political contexts in the
United States we despite not knowing
very much and being pretty naive about
Sweden who seem to want to emulate it um
I think that the most interesting
example of this Switching gears a little
bit is Bernie Sanders
um so Bernie Sanders will so frequently
call himself a Democratic Socialist and
tout socialism as the model he doesn't
mean Venezuela style socialism he
doesn't mean Cuban style socialism he
means Swedish socialism I think it's
worth uh playing a bit of Bernie Sanders
rhetoric just to really dig into a
couple of the specific claims that he
makes when he you know touts the Swedish
DSA model let's roll that clip and I I'm
curious to hear you react to some of the
specifics that he foreign someone who
calls himself a socialist to be elected
president United States well so long as
we know what democratic socialism is and
if we know that in countries in
Scandinavia like Denmark Norway Sweden
they are very Democratic countries
obviously the voted turnout is a lot
higher than it is in the United States
in those countries Health Care is a
right of all people and those countries
college education graduate school is
free in those countries retirement
benefits Child Care are stronger than in
the United States of America and in
those countries by and launch government
works for ordinary people in the middle
class rather than as is the case right
now in our country uh for the
billionaires I can hear the Republican
attack ad right now he wants America to
look more like Scandinavia that's right
that's right
so uh and by the way that was from ABC
this week uh when Bert in 2015 when
Bernie was running for president and
some of the things he mentioned there
turn uh turnout a more generous social
safety net free college more General
equality you know you mentioned some of
the University Market yes yes so
um
is that something that is you know
crucial to Sweden's uh society and kind
of cultural success
you know this is why Sweden is not a
Libertarian Paradise we might have free
markets but we do have a very generous
welfare state and uh it's true that many
of these things are are handed out by by
the government not always it's funded by
the government at least often there are
private providers but the thing is we
pay for these things ourselves that's an
incredibly important point to to make
because you know there's this pipe dream
of Bernie Sanders and others that this
will somehow be paid for by the rich but
Sweden learned in the 1970s that you if
if you have you
you can pick one a big generous welfare
states or you can make the rich pay for
it all you can't have both if you have a
universal generous welfare state uh in
if and make the rich pay for it all they
will stop being rich they will move they
will stop starting those businesses and
the IPS of the future will move again
instead you have to get most of the
taxes from low and middle income High
holes households that's the Dirty Little
Secret of the Swedish welfare state that
the the Socialists loves the poor
taxpayers because they are reliable
loyal taxpayers they don't Dodge they
don't move to Monaco they don't have tax
attorneys so we have the bulk of our
government revenue coming from
um Regional local income taxes which are
flat income taxes not Progressive and
even the sort of the the national uh
level kicks in uh
young fairly fairly unfairly low incomes
also things like a value-addy tax at 25
percent in General on most Goods which
is obviously regressive the poor pay as
much as the rich when they buy food and
in in taxes and this means that when the
oecd club of mostly rich countries look
at different tax systems around the
world they say that the Swedish system
is one of the least progressive tax
systems of all much less Progressive
than the United States because America's
welfare states is so small so you can
rely more on the rich whereas here we
all have to to pay for it so the Swedish
welfare state mostly just redistributes
over an individual's life cycle we get
lots of stuff when we're young and in
preschool and school and then we work
hard and pay for it all and then we get
much of it back in healthcare and and
retirement benefits uh which mostly
means that yes we get lots of stuff but
we pay for it all and it means that
nothing much is different uh from paying
it straight out of pocket than the fact
that we only get it back when and if the
government decides that this is a
valuable thing this is how you should
spend your money it's so interesting
that the Socialists keep coming back to
Sweden and I think that's because all
their favorite countries constantly fail
every Cuban Venezuela end up with bread
lines and uh Millions trying to escape
from that that horror show but they
always have Sweden it seems so friendly
and successful and and yet socialist
well the problem of course is that we
have been socialists in Sweden and we
have been successful but never at the
same time that's what Saunders and the
others fail to realize we had that
period in the 1970s and 1980s when Eden
was doubling the size of public
consumption raising taxes regulating
everything and price controls and what
have you and this is the moment when
Bernie Sanders and all those who are
sort of
stuck in the 1970s this is what they
still remember look at Sweden they are
socialists but they're also one of the
richest countries on the planet it seems
to be working in Sweden the problem of
course is that it's like that old joke
how do you end up with a small fortune
well you start with a large fortune and
then you waste most of it and that's
what Sweden did in the 70s and 80s we
were one of the richest countries on the
planet before this experiment and that
was based on a 100 year period of
limited government free markets free
trade as late as 1960 we had lower taxes
than the United States and most European
countries this brought us all the wealth
and all those successful International
companies the Ikeas and stuff that
brought us so much wealth that
politicians thought that they could
redistribute everything
and begin to just check up spending and
taxes well they couldn't because the 70s
and 80s that's the one period in modern
Swedish economic history when we lagged
behind other countries this is the
moment when we didn't create a single
net job in the private sector and when
entrepreneurs and businesses left Sweden
Ikea left Sweden tetrapak left Sweden
most successful entrepreneurs left
because it was impossible to do business
in Sweden and this all ended in a
terrible financial crash in the early
1990s so that was a brief period of time
and it's one that we don't want to go
back to is we not even Swedish
socialists even they say that okay we
went too far and the Social Democratic
finance minister at the time said it was
actually absurd and perverse in many
ways what we were trying to do and since
then Sweden has again become successful
but that's based on a new period of
liberalization and of economic reform so
today if Bernie Sanders want to imitate
Sweden he would have to reform Social
Security partially privatize it he would
have to open up and privatize much of a
product markets deregulate abolish
occupational licensing reduce many taxes
reduce corporate taxes from the U.S
level abolish property taxes and
inheritance taxes and stuff like that
implementing National School voucher
systems so private schools get the same
funding as as public ones so Sweden
today is not what he remembers from the
1970s it's it's a much better and and
Freer place than it was back then in a
lot of ways this almost feels a little
bit like a Libertarian Paradise not on
every level but I certainly look at you
know obviously Sweden has some areas
that absolutely uh fly in the face of
that like I know homeschooling is banned
in Sweden uh which is very sad but
school choice is massive in Sweden and
then when you look at yes there's a
whole bunch of public sector jobs a
whole bunch of government jobs programs
but one thing that's actually really
interesting that I know you've commented
on a fair bit is the fact that union
relationship relations in Sweden are a
lot less fraught than in the United
States so in the United States you so
frequently see
um you know teachers unions and cop
unions essentially allowing some of the
worst lowest performing employees to to
fester in these roles to never be fired
to have Perpetual constant Eternal job
security completely shielded from the
consequences of their laziness or their
bad actions you see a ton of political
power exercised by unions in the United
States is this different in Sweden it
seems like it's a little bit less toxic
you know relations in workplaces aren't
as confrontational in Sweden uh as it is
in in most other places and uh I would
say the trade unions are more respected
in Sweden broadly than in other places
but as one there was this great
conversation between two trade unionists
an American and a Swede when the
Americans said oh we would love to have
the kind of respect and attention and
power as you do in Sweden and the
Swedish Trade union has said in that
case you have to deserve it and and
that's one major difference this shocks
Americans the Swedish trade unions one
of their most important goals is to make
sure that wage increases aren't too high
aren't true that they don't get too high
wages because that will make their
businesses less competitive so the sort
of the the Trade union Federation is
traveling around the country and trying
to sort of get the local trade unions to
relax don't try to get everything at
once because we're a small open economy
we have to stay competitive and make
sure that wages don't increase faster
than productivity
um and that's obviously not the same
trade unions as you've seen in other
places some explain this with the fact
that we have much higher Trade union
membership rates in Sweden than in other
places 70 80 percent even in in White
Collar professions and as some
economists like Monica Olson has pointed
out if your trade unions are represent
such a large part of the population then
you can't just
get everything on everybody else's
expense in that case you have to think
about the competitiveness of of the
whole economy you're also a consumer so
it doesn't make sense to uh Lobby for
tariffs for example so many things are
different in Sweden than than in the US
thank you for watching our conversation
with Johan Norberg for the full
conversation go here for more Clips go
here